i am nick gillespie with reason TV we're  looking for 500 new donors to help us  under right our efforts to bring you the  very best in libertarian video  journalism including documentary  segments hosted by myself and drew carey  the reason about TV i'm drew carey and  I'm out of here in a haircut in-depth  interviews with cutting-edge capitalist  like Whole Foods CEO John Mackey and  humorous PJ O'Rourke I started out on  the left because I was a kid and it was  the 60s and and the girls on the Left  would do it in real time reactions to  news events ranging from the Tea Party  protests of Washington DC to the  announcement that Barack Obama had won  the nobel peace prize he interrupt this  report with news that Barack Obama has  just received a tony award for best  spoken word performance by a lead actor  let the wild rumpus start please give  what you can and will keep them coming  you